donc vous avez fait 65 km la fois
précédente
donc l'objectif c'est de faire au moins
65 ou un peu plus peut-être aussi
moi je trouve que ça serait pas mal je
trouve que ça serait pas mal pédalez sur
son lit d'hôpital c'est une habituel et
pourtant c'est le quotidien de ces
patients en dialyse de la clinique de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye depuis 2020 en
plus des séances quotidiennes de vélo un
tour de France est organisé une fois par
an les patients se défient sur des
étapes de la Grande Boucle
j'ai envie de gagner ce que vous voulez
une belle coupe exactement j'ai envie de
ramener à la coupe à la maison
rendre les trois séances de dialyse
hebdomadaire plus agréable c'est aussi
l'objectif du dispositif pour Mohamed en
dialyse depuis deux ans les bienfaits se
font ressentir autant sur le corps que
sur l'esprit sur le plan physique sur le
plan moral ça m'aide beaucoup ça m'a
aidé à maigrir ça aussi ça fait du bien
pour la dialyse en fait le son est sorti
le mieux ça dialyse mieux ça fait du
bien de se dépasser parfois même si on
est fatigué ou parce qu'avec la dialyse
c'est un peu fatigant quand même
franchement trop bien moi je suis trop
content d'avoir cette chance et de
participer au Tour de France de en
dialyse malgré la fatigue la motivation
ne faiblit pas et les
parties reproduisent les étapes du Tour
de France donc ça dure un peu plus de 15
jours et à la fin des 15 jours ils ont
effectué complètement leur tour de
France et donc on organise une petite
remise des prix on a à peu près presque
une centaine de patients qui participent
à ce Tour de France et donc on est très
contents parce qu'ils sont assez
enthousiastes ils prennent ça comme un
challenge et comme chaque sportif
nécessite son coach le kinésithérapeute
motive le peloton c'est que parfois
c'est pas facile on a des journées un
peu plus compliquées cette fois ils ont
passé des mauvaises nuits c'est un petit
peu dur comme dans comme dans la vie
d'un sportif au final et du coup faut
parfois les motiver et il faut juste
savoir trouver les bons mots quoi mais
généralement ça passe bien reste
maintenant à savoir qui sera le maillot
jaune du centre d'emodialyse de la
clinique réponse le 1er juillet date
officielle du lancement du Tour